[Music]
what if I told you we could get a song
written in five 10
[Music]
minutes my thoughts are
running
wow we want to make an album right we
want to get some songs written I like
music but I'm not a
[Music]
[Applause]
musician this is the time where you
could come up with an idea that actually
changes the world
these kids they digging me I'm digging
them and we about to make some great
music most of us just want to leave
something that you know people can
remember us
[Applause]
by the album's really just changed my
whole life you love
it anything is possible when you just
put your heart into
it
that's what music does it brings people
[Applause]
[Music]
together